jetzt haben wir den salat die chinesen
sind voll wütend auf uns ja ja weil
heiko maas unser außenminister in berlin
diesen hongkong aktivisten joshua bonn
getroffen hat dabei hatten die chinesen
uns das ausdrücklich verboten
dieser zwischenfall wird eine sehr
negative beeinträchtigung für die
bilaterale beziehung ausüben heißt dass
wir haben krieg das passt gerade ganz
schlecht die gorch fock ist kaputt
schon ende august haben viele nicht
mitbekommen hat peking eine
bundestagsdelegation nicht nach china
einreisen lassen weil da eine grüne
dabei war die die behandlung der uiguren
kritisiert hat und wenn wie neulich
geschehen deutsche abgeordnete tibeter
treffen schreibt die chinesische
botschaft an herrn schäuble und sagt ihm
er soll seine leute gefälligst mal
diszipliniert wirklich ist wahnsinn wie
offen die hier bei uns in deutschland
macht worte sprechen und sie kaufen
natürlich weiter alles auf sogar dietmar
wischmeyer das logbuch
[Musik]
wismars logbuch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten genossen
willkommen in germany der westlichste
provinz der volksrepublik china
ja spinnen denn hier alle chinesen
wütend machen weil man sie schon genug
ärger mit donald trump erdogan und dem
borkenkäfer
die chinesen sind die letzten die noch
freiwillig unsere autos kaufen wie so
muss heiko maas dieses burschel aus
hongkong treffen an dem einen tag wo er
mal nicht zu enge anzüge shoppen geht
macht im saarland aufwachsen eigentlich
blöd gewesen bin stinksauer
haben sie das gesehen als merkel gerade
peking war haben wir extra den stuhl
tiefer gestellt wird sie da wie in der
kindertagesstätte von den chinesen
lernen heißt siegen lernen alle bürger
werden da rund um die uhr überwacht und
nach einem ausgeklügelten punktesystem
bewertet und dann hat er mir die tage
gezeigt wo die ehrlichen bürger
aufgelistet waren und die vertrauens
rechner
so heißt es dann in diesem system und
vertrauen sprecherin nummer eins in
diesem monat war die frau wang deren
hund auf den rasen geschickt hat und
wenn die benimm spirale voll ist geht es
ab ins lager davon träumt doch auch bei
uns der ostkotte im vorgebirge oder
nicht jetzt
ab dem nächsten jahr unterliegen auch
deutsche firmen in china dem punkte
wahnsinn siemens-chef käser wird das
nicht gefallen aber in china wählt man
seine worte mit vorsicht das ist ein
thema das sehr
interessiert aber was passiert wenn sie
den käse demnächst beim auf den rasen
kacken erwischen
da haben wir jetzt aber richtig
interessant
joe kaeser hat völlig recht finden wir
uns endlich damit ab die chinesen machen
hier die regeln
und vielleicht haben sie auch manchmal
recht wer weiß möglicherweise hilft das
abgesenkte horn vom rhinozeros
gegenreaktion schwächer weil wir lieber
froh dass die chinesischen freunde uns
nicht über den reichs bröse damit sie
wieder ein hoch kriegen ich sage das
alles nicht um angst vor dem gelben man
zu machen
politisch korrekt da kann man es nicht
ausdrücken dem gelben man verdanken wir
es dass wir uns überhaupt noch firmen in
den gelben seiten stehen einfach mal
dankbar sein
auch für die neuen pandas wenige im
berliner zoo das sind die süßesten pott
hässlichen bambus raten die ich je
gesehen habe
die berliner wollten die ernsthaft hong
und kommunen
zum glück konnte altmaier das verhindern
jetzt heißen sie hohe und 3 das war es
von mir mein name ist dietmar wischmeyer
und ich bedanke mich beim botschafter
der volksrepublik china der diesem
beitrag ermöglicht hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kann man alles
begeistern schließt gefälligst ein abo
ab sofort